[Música]
hoy se celebra el día mundial de los
océanos con una cifra se que nosotros
nos invitan a reflexionar sobre el mal
que estamos causando debido a nuestras
prácticas actuales de pesca manejo de
basuras y también los residuos que cada
día nos acercamos son más al punto de no
retorno si no actuamos ya y también con
contundencia según datos de la
organización de naciones unidas más del
80% de las aguas residuales
resultantes de actividades humanas se
vierten en los ríos o el mar sin ningún
tipo de tratamiento lo que provoca su
contaminación la salud de los océanos se
encuentra en la actualidad en un punto
de infección al igual que el bienestar
de todo lo que depende de ellos espero
yo que hoy debe servir como una
oportunidad de aumentar la conciencia
mundial sobre los beneficios que
obtenemos en nuestros océanos así como
nuestro deber individual y colectivo de
utilizar sus recursos de manera
sostenible para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día del es maximiliano bello asesor de
políticas públicas oceánicas de ejemplo
gracias maximiliano por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le pregunto en un plano general digamos
la situación actual de los océanos y
también la importancia para nosotros
muchísimas gracias y buen buen día y
feliz día digamos con cuando no sea tan
feliz porque efectivamente el tema está
en una situación bien compleja no
y me refiero al océano porque un solo
sistema conectado
justamente tenemos montones de amenazas
en los últimos 50 años básicamente ha
habido un aumento de tremendos tanto de
la explotación como la contaminación y
decía también que cada vez jugando un
rol más importante el cambio climático
pero sin embargo se nos olvida muchas
veces que el océano es la fuente de la
vida en el planeta más cuando haces tus
cantos el
agua está buscando agua líquida sabemos
ya que hay agua congelada que hay quien
lo digamos en otras partes del universo
pero sin embargo no hemos encontrado un
planeta que tenga esta capacidad 70 por
ciento del planeta está cubierto por
este océano que finalmente ha sido la
fuente de la diversidad y de la vida
misma la misma propia vida del cierto de
la humanidad
ahora maximiliano como estamos dañando
nosotros los océanos y también con este
daño como podemos recuperarlos
efectivamente la principal amenaza el
kilo científico indica en la sobrepesca
no pues ya sabemos que prácticamente el
90% de los costes quiero ser ese equipo
que se consumen que se extraen y se
preparan para la venta están en una
situación de sobrepesca sabemos también
por ejemplo hay una discusión hoy día
que comienza a vivir en ginebra en la
mesa en la organización mundial de
comercio que nos indica que se gastan 35
mil millones de dólares en subsidiar
pesquerías que están destruyendo sobre
esa pesca esa misma ecosistema esa misma
especie y por lo tanto en la sobrepesca
en la principal hoy día fuente de
destrucción y de pérdida de la
biodiversidad pero si eso uno le suma la
contaminación que hemos visto muchísimo
en estos últimos años cierto el plástico
pero más la contaminación de las aguas
del con un químico con herbicida cierto
con fertilizante eso está teniendo un
efecto tremendo y luego sumado a eso
también es el cambio climático que
produce el calentamiento del agua
por lo tanto de esa oxigenación perdía
el oxígeno en el agua obviamente todo la
mayor parte de no animales que viven en
el agua como nosotros en en tierra
cierto también viven del oxígeno la
acidificación cierto
y otros efectos que están ocurriendo
producto de eso y luego la composición
de todas estas amenazas juntas y eso
está llevando al colapso se ha hablado
hace poco se presentó un paper cierto
que habla del potencial colapso de la
especie digamos de todos los animales
marinos de todas las especies marinas al
2300 es una realidad que está ocurriendo
hoy día y que si no cambiamos porque
todos estos efectos los hemos producido
nosotros si no cambiamos la forma en que
utilizamos
si no protegemos lo que va quedando
entonces no lo vamos a lograr salvar lo
sean
estamos muy tarde ya para actuar
maximiliano nos estamos muy tarde yo he
visto digamos en algunos lugares podemos
es posible también recuperar zonas
importantes si uno tiene sí tenemos la
capacidad de decir lo que va quedando
sobre todo y creo que un ambiente muy
positivo al respecto eso estamos
hablando de hoy día los científicos
dicen que al menos el 30% del océano
tiene que ser tiene que ser protegido
estamos viendo que muchos países están
avanzando en esa línea el chile y yo
estoy en esto de los ángeles chile está
llamando a los países de
américa del lado pacífico cierto a crear
un gran corredor que va desde patagonia
alaska ese es un tipo de cosas que son
ambiciosas que tenemos que seguir
haciendo mediante la difusión de los
subsidios que mencionaba que es
importante cortar los subsidios que
están llevando a las obras a la
explotación tenemos que también hacer
moratoria a la minería submarina que es
una gran amenaza al océano tenemos
también que proteger justamente el alta
mar 60 por ciento de ese 70 por ciento
del del océano está fuera de las
jurisdicciones
y por lo tanto es prácticamente mar de
nadie y muchos están destruir siguen
destruyendo cierto
no hay la capacidad de proteger o de
generar reglas hay entonces hay algo
oportunidades y hoy día si todavía el
océano tiene lo que puede llevarnos a
salvarlo no tienen el 10 por ciento de
los tiburones es tremendo es terrible
pero a la vez que el 10 por ciento somos
capaces hemos demostrado la posibilidad
como con las ballenas de que las
especies vuelvan cierto a
crecer a poblar cierto el océano y creo
que como humanos que son muy
inteligentes tenemos esa capacidad para
hacerlo la importancia también de los
corales maximiliano en la salud de los
océanos hemos visto también el
blanqueamiento de muchos de muchas
barreras de coral qué implicaciones
tiene esto
en los corales es cierto los arrecifes
de coral
son probablemente algunos de los
sistemas más importantes para el océano
porque son realmente el hogar el refugio
para muchas especies por tanto
concentrar una diversidad importantísima
de especies pero además en el coral en
sí es una asociación cierta entre un
alga y una anémona o un animal digamos y
lo que lo que hace es que también está
secuestrando carbono y como digo y a la
vez mantiene esta estos lugares
impresiones son verdaderas porque con
eso la ciudad pero es todo vivo es
conducir los edificios y yo tengo mi
espalda estuvieran vivos en sí mismos
esos son los arrecifes de coral y los
estamos perdiendo a un ritmo tremendo
está muy bien que prácticamente el 50%
de los arrecifes coral se han perdido y
hoy día que sabemos y llevamos una
trayectoria de tres a cuatro grados
aumentó de tres a cuatro grados de
temperatura por el cambio climático
entonces sabemos hoy día que solamente
con dos grados de aumento
tenemos todos los arrecifes de coral es
eso puede tener efectos tremendamente
grande en cadenas sobre el océano sobre
el planeta pero además va a tener
efectos tremendamente importantes sobre
la humanidad sobre los millones de
personas que viven asociadas de alguna
forma al arrecife de coral en respuesta
también a la situación grave y de iu
también de digamos de de como hoy día
algunas de esas
características
ecosistemas están en una situación
compleja y tenemos que solucionarlo